we've seen tons of lawsuits being filed
with headline grabbing numbers being
filed for
say billions of dollars the billion
dollar lawsuit from dominion or
billions of dollars being sought from
facebook and google but here's a secret
that only lawyers know
that number is largely bs the thing is
the plaintiff can put whatever
allegations they want
into the complaint and the number that
they seek at the very end
of the complaint the prayer for relief
is going to have
a large number often if you're launching
a lawsuit that has as much of a pr
component as it does an actual legal
basis then you're gonna want to grab
some headlines and a lot of these
lawsuits have
done that it doesn't mean that they're
entitled to that amount of money doesn't
mean that they're going to be awarded
that amount of money from the judge or
the jury
it just means that a plaintiff's lawyer
wants to cover their bases
and they want to make sure that they're
not hamstrung by seeking a small amount
upfront so they will put
basically any number that they want at
the end of the complaint so just
remember that next time you see a
lawsuit that is seeking billions of
dollars from someone else that number is
largely made up